hello everyone and welcome to another
top tier game from the final round of
this year's data still Masters Edition
it's Arjun irrigation versus Magnus
Carlson and by now you already know that
Anish giri won the tournament it was a
spectacular performance by him but
Magnus of course did not know this going
into the final round going into the
final round he was not Rebecca dusatrov
who was leading the tournament or rather
leading um uh Everyone by by either a
half a half a point uh by that I mean
leading anishikiri by half a point and
leading Magnus Carlsen and Wesley so by
a full point so going into this round uh
Magnus still had a chance at
um to catch up the abdulsatrov and go
into tie bricks maybe if Abdul saturov
loses the uh to Jordan Palm Forest like
he did in the final round however Anish
won his game and against Rapport and uh
won the tournament but you guys
requested this one it's a really wild
crazy game very complicated one uh so
you better have uh plenty of time to die
just this one let's check it out and see
what happened Arjun with the white
pieces opens with Knight to F3 he goes
for the ready opening uh Knight to F6 by
Magnus G3 and B6 now preparing to think
it to the light score Bishop with Bishop
to G2 and now Bishop to B7 uh we have
castles and now Pawn to G6 going into uh
the the king's Indian attack of the reti
we have Pawn to C4 and now Bishop to G7
fincato in both Bishops uh D4 and now we
have Castles by Magnus we have Pawn to
D5 grabbing more space in the center and
now Knight to A6 so this has all been
played before nothing new here Knights
the C3 and not Knight to C5 and
interestingly uh the position has been
reached and it has been reached by Arjun
negregation in one of his games from
2018 a game that he lost but we're gonna
get uh to that yeah and here you guys
are probably wondering can uh one play
B4 here and the the answer is no the
this is one of the rare positions where
it's not okay to play B4 and you you
might already suspect why but I'm just
going to show you if before you can
actually play Knight F the E4 just put
pressure on the C3 Knight and x-ray that
Rook on A1 and now if Knight captures an
A4 You're Gonna Play Knight captures on
e4 and now after Knight to D4 which is
why it's a best reply uh you will play
Knight the C3 attack the the queen here
and after Queen to D2 Now You're Gonna
Play Bishop characters on D4 and white
cannot recapture if White recaptures
Knight captures I need to check picks up
the queen so white has to throw an
in-between move and I switch into a
bishop to B2 and okay white will win the
material back but not all of it uh here
Knight captures I need to with check uh
Queen captures Anita and now the short
characters and B2 Queen captures on B2
and if you count to the pawns black is
just up a pawn and white has nothing to
show for it so that's why uh this is one
of the very rare yeah positions where B4
is not the best movie if anything it
could be the worst move uh so here
Knights the D4 is played uh just
grabbing more space opening up the light
Square Bishop uh and here we have Ponte
E5 by Magnus we have Knight back to C2
and now Pawn to A5 we have Ponta B3 and
D6 and up until this point uh we've been
following the game Arjun already played
in 2018 against Evgeni Romanov uh the
game that he lost in the in the BL
tournament uh but in that game uh Arjun
played Rook the B1 here he goes for the
immediate Pawn to E4 and it is now as of
move 12 that we have a completely new
game so okay Magnus goes to Bishop to C8
he wants to re-maneuver the bishop as uh
well it's not very useful on this
diagonal now that the center is closed
we have Knight to A3 going for that B5
square and now Knight the E8 Magnus is
now ready to execute F5 he has very nice
support for uh for for the push Knight
eight the B5 and now Bishop to D7 we
have Rook to B1 uh and now Pawn to F5 so
Magnus goes for the Breakthrough we have
Ponta F3 and now Pawn to F4
uh putting more pressure on on arjun's
King side we have Ponte A3 now preparing
B4 and pawn to G5 with Pawn to B4 that
each player pushing on on the other
sides of the board uh Knight to B7 and
now Pawn to G4 closing the the king side
somewhere you can still open it you can
play H5 uh and that's exactly what
Magnus does so Pawn to H5 we have H3 and
now Rook to F7 uh King to F2 Arjun now
has the uh the brilliant plan of
Shifting the king all the way uh to the
to the queen side where it's gonna be a
safer and then he can use his Rooks and
queen to open up the king side and maybe
even attack magnus's King so Bishop to
f8 uh we have Rook the G1 and now Rook
the H7 uh the The Rook is now coming to
the H file and maybe the other row can
also join him uh Bishop to F1 we have
Knight to F6 and now King the E1 Arjun
continues bringing the king over to the
queen side Queen to C 8 and now you are
probably already
figuring out what Magnus is doing Rook
the B2 we have knighted the d8 and now
uh Queen to D3 so just improving the uh
the the the uh the pieces Knight to F7
and now King to D1 further bringing the
king over to the queen side with Bishop
to E7 by Magnus and now King the C2 and
now okay the king is now on the queen
side makes sense to open the queen side
a captures on B4 a captures and now H
captures on G4 we have eight H captors
and now Rook the A1 by Magnus preparing
to bring the other Rook over to H2 so
Rook to B1 countering this you could try
try some other moves but Rook to B1 uh
is also very nice so just attacking the
rook and A1 and now Rook the H2 with
check-in situation on the clock here is
Arjun some 35 minutes and Magnus 50
minutes this is move 31 so 9 more moves
have to be played until you reach time
control all and again you could just
move the king king to B3 it's a it's a
nice move Bishop to eat you can play
that you can block with Rook to G2 and
Arjun goes for Rook to G2 and now Rook
captures on G2 Bishop captures and The
Rook captures on B1 so Magnus eliminates
the Rooks of the board King captures
and now comes the move that he had in
mind but it was important to eliminate
the heavy artillery of the board Knight
captures on G4 and that means that now
this will become a past pawn and this
will become a pass Pawn so uh a piece
for two two connected pass pawns is
definitely worth it so F captures with
Bishop captures and G4 and now Arjun
really uh uh you know uh went uh deep
into uh think mode and he found uh
Bishop to F3 and he spent some 20
minutes on this move now the situation
on the clock is 11 minutes for Arjun and
again 50 minutes for Magnus move 36 so
four more moves need to be made to uh
for time control to be reached and
Magnus has a lot a lot of work to do
here uh what do you do do you capture do
you go back do you go back this way many
things to consider and I will just show
the the more interesting one so let's
say Bishop to D7 and it seems like a
fine move you you are preparing to push
G4 or G3 G2 G1 and just win the game the
problem is after Queen to D1 there's
just no good way to do this because now
if you play Pawn to G4 there's Knight A7
and now look at this the queen is
hanging and the queen cannot keep an eye
on the G4 Pawn anymore so now Queen to
A6 has to be played now you play Bishop
G4 you attack the bishop here Queen
captures on C4 attacking the Knight but
now Bishop captures on these seven Queen
captures on C3 and now Knights the C6
and white is just uh White is just
winning here there is no good way for
black to do anything here for example
Bishop to F6 You're Gonna Play Queen to
H5 and now Bishop to E6 is coming so
Queen to B3 with check you're gonna play
King to A1 and after a few more checks
Queen to C3 Bishop to B2 Queen to E1
with check King A2 even Queen captures
an E4 now Bishop to E6 goes after the
Knight Queen to C4 with check you're
gonna play King to B1 let's say queen to
F1 check King to C2 or or A2 doesn't
really matter Queen to have to check in
the B3 are gonna play Queen to G3 check
Bishop to C3 and now okay you can defend
the Knight but it doesn't matter knight
uh sorry Knight to B8
uh very very strong and after King to f8
and pinning Knight to D7 with check King
t7 for example and not Knight captures
on F6 Queen captures and the bishop to
E1 uh threatens the to pick up the queen
here so Queen to G7 you're still gonna
deliver a nice check here King the E8
the defended Bishop on E6 is just an
absolute monster and now look at this
King C4 King is coming to B5 to C6 and
black is without a move for example
Ponte E4 will be met with King to B5 if
you can continue pushing Pawn to F3 King
to C6 and now you cannot push F to the
bishop covers that you cannot push uh E3
as uh Queen captures on F3 you can't
move the Knight you can't move the queen
because the the Knight hangs there's no
move here for black you just resign you
can you can give one check but after
King B7 again you have to go back to
defend the Knight then just King
captures on C7 uh everything falls apart
if let's say B5 you can just trade
everything Bishop captures Queen
captures captures captures you stop the
E3 Pawn from advancing you win the E5
pawn and Advance your Pawn to Victory so
not not much to be done here so Bishop
to D7 although it seems like a
no-brainer would actually be very bad
for black another thing you could do is
capture the bishop just Bishop captures
an F3 but now Queen captures an F3 and
the G4 is met with Queen to H1 and now
let's say G3 You're Gonna Play Queen to
H5 and you don't feel very very
comfortable here for example Queen to f8
King A2 and now G2 you of course wanna
advance that pawn uh promoted to a queen
now Knights the E2 and it doesn't seem
like you will be promoting any of those
spawns anytime soon the Blackwing cannot
help out with the defense uh not not
much to be done here uh so uh while
possible maybe not the best course of
action so Bishop D7 not not the greatest
Bishop to F3 okay but not the best uh
Bishop to H3 is what Magnus goes for
and okay uh we have Bishop to H5 now uh
and here comes Pawn to G4 uh we have
knighted the E2 uh bringing the Knight
to help out with the defense here Bishop
to F1 pinning the Knight with Queen to
D1 and pinning and now Bishop to G2 with
Bishop to G6 preparing Bishop to F5 to
go after the G4 pawn and Knight to G5
now and here uh we have Knight beat the
C3 now it's very interesting why not
just go for Bishop the F5 Bishop to F5
attacks the pawn here it does seem to be
a very nice move uh the problem is
Bishop captures on e4 comes with checks
so you don't really care about this
bishop here as the white will have to
trade and you just lost the pawn so
Knight to beat the C3 adding another
Defender now preparing Bishop to F5 and
only now we have Bishop to F3 uh we have
Queen to F1 again and pinning now Bishop
to F5 can be played the magnets would
probably uh shift the queen over to the
a file or maybe even maybe maybe even
the E8 as that square would open up
maybe you want to play Queen to eat then
queen queen here maybe Queen here so
while it is possible Arjun decides to go
for Queen to F1 first on pinning but now
King to G7 attacks the bishop Bishop to
F5 and now Magnus goes Queen to h8 we
have Knight captures on F4 and this is
what Arjun was uh planning probably if
he didn't plan to give the the Knight
back he would bring the queen over to D3
instead of F1 but it's just a very hard
to find the move for white so he he
Figures it's best to give back the Pista
to grab two pawns he captures and the
bishop capture so restoring material uh
Bishop to F6 by Magnus attacking the
undefended Knight and the queen to C1
defending the Knight and also putting
pressure on the Knight on G5 so Knights
the F7 and now Knight to B5 putting
pressure on the C7 Pawn but now Magnus
shifts the queen over to A8 and look at
how Magnus is just shifting the queen A8
hhd it looks
incredible but uh I mean it's it's the
open file the queen will be deadliest
there and now the problem is uh how how
do you continue with white if you trade
Queens for example Queen to A3 uh black
will very happily trade captures
captures for example Knight a bishop E5
tried to claim the G3 Square tried to
advance that pawn and after Bishop D3
guarding the G1 Square you will now play
some like Knight H6 attack the bishop
and uh well I try try to get push that
pawn to Victory uh it's much better
position for black whether it would be
winning all depends on how both of them
would play but okay here we have Ponte
E5 Arjun decides to go for a pawn
sacrifice to close this uh diagonal so
it gives him time to re-maneuver his
Bishop over to C3 and try to counter
magnus's strong dark Square Bishop as
this is uh well almost a dragon so D
captures an E5 with Bishop to D2 and now
okay now if E4 is just gonna play Bishop
to C3 but now Magnus goes Knight to D6
uh we have Bishop to H6 check first king
to F7 now Knight captures and D6 with
check C captures on D6 and now Bishop to
G5 hoping to get the the queen into the
game but now again look at this Quinta
h8 I mean Magnus just shifting the queen
back and forth this is absolutely
incredible uh and now how do you
continue this the problem is if you
trade let's say Bishop captures Queen
characters or even better King captures
the the bishop is attacked once you move
the bishop just Bishop to E4 check and
you're getting destroyed here there's
nothing to do for example King A1 G3 and
now after Queen to F1 check You're Gonna
Play not this this would be terrible
Queen to F7 would win the game but just
King to G6 and now after Queen to F7
check you can even go to G5 any Queen t7
check you go to F4 and if Queen to f72
if you go to E3 uh no more no more moves
for white here uh So that obviously
doesn't work so Arjun goes back Bishop
to E3 puts pressure on the B6 pawn and
now Magnus goes for Pawn to E4 opens up
this diagonal once again and it's very
very hard to find moves for Arjun he
goes for Bishop captures on B6 even
though uh it's uh not not the most
precise move but all the moves are
losing for him so now of course he wants
to start advancing that pass that soon
to be passed Pawn but Magnus is
completely winning here so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
quickest way to Victory well I'll give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
another long journey for the queen and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show no it's not Queen to A8 even
though it would be very poetic if it was
it's a queen to H2 so congratulations to
everyone who found this but other moves
were also very very much winning but
here it's just um impossible to defend
uh the problem is now uh whatever you
play let's say you play C5 because
that's kind of White's only counter play
you will play Bishop to E2 and now uh
Bishop to D3 of course will be will be
game over so you have to stop this let's
say Bishop characters on e4 but now
Queen to E5 attacks the bishop and also
threatens Queen to A1 check and you
cannot uh defend against both if let's
say queen to see if onto C6 you're just
gonna deliver a nice Queen T1 check
Queen to a king desito and queen A2
check the bishop prevents uh King from
going to D1 and D3 you have to block
here and this will just be Checkmate so
that's why Queen to H2 is Unstoppable so
here Arjun tries Bush back to G1 this
attacks the the black queen uh Queen to
E2 now we have pawned the B5 advancing
the past Pawn but now just Queen to D3
with check and he was in this position
animal 56 that Arjun arigasi resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here
uh the problem is uh you are in check
you have two moves you can block with
Queen to C2 or go King to A2 if you go
King to A2 it doesn't really matter just
Bishop to D1 and there's no defense
against uh Queen to B3 Checkmate if you
try Queen A3 then this is Checkmate
Queen to C2 check Queen between Queen
capture Sun B2 and if you don't after
Queen to D3 check you could also play
Queen to C2 block it like this but now
just Queen to A3 and as the king is cut
off from the C2 Square this will now be
Checkmate there is no good way to uh I
mean you could prolong it a little bit
Bishop E6 checking the G7 and now Queen
to A2 but only for a moment Queen to B4
with checking to C2 now Queen to C3 with
checking to B1 and now Queen to E1 with
check King to C2 and queen to D1 is only
one of the many checkmates that are
possible so after Queen to D3 uh Arjun
resigns and the Magnus gets his
well-deserved Victory but even this and
even his spectacular play in the second
half of the tournament was not enough to
bounce back after those two losses to a
niche and then don't direct
he does uh in the end if you didn't see
the standings in the previous video
These are the final standings so he does
share second place with Abdul Satur of
now after an incredible performance but
it is Anish giri who wins the Tata steel
and I mean that is absolutely incredible
it took him like I think last time he
won was 11 years ago and he was always
close but never never quite got there
but also one of the things that I
mentioned in the previous video If you
haven't watched that eight and a half
it's really been a while since someone
won Tata still with eight and a half
usually it's it's like a nine nine and a
half even ten maybe but here the
competition was so Fierce that and no
player could achieve more than than
eight and a half that Anish was able to
at The Gather uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh very nicely
done by by Magnus winning with the black
pieces
um uh like this uh uh I I first I
thought it would be as there are three
Indian players in this tournament and I
thought Magnus would get a draw against
all three which would be incredible for
the Indian prodigies uh but uh Magnus
does does win his
um uh Indian encounter as he he drew
with Prague
but he managed to defeat Arjun Erica is
here so it will uh maybe next year but
uh you know they are becoming stronger
and stronger so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Russell Scott last amount sir a
friend's book called ravishing reptiles
YouTube and Sasha vidler for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all we'll see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
have a game that I haven't covered from
the Tata steel Challengers or Masters do
use hashtag suggestion and I will go
over it see you soon